I am [ __ ] right let's gone can we learn
about when you joined a cult please yeah
so listeners at home we have been
begging him to tell us I think or
research should do too for our ones fine
two to one worked right so I'll do both
of your requests cult and big pivot
Euler
so we the the I think all of these
stories start from ok position of like
being experimental and not what you're
having such FOMO of like but what if
there is something to it what if what if
I do spend three weeks in the pool yep
underwater two hours a day and actually
it is slightly beneficial so the cult
was something that was recommended to me
I thought I'm gonna join it now I
probably shouldn't say the name of it
because can you give it an alternative
name yeah
Grubb leave up so cool the joined the
grub bebop cult and it basically
involves going to barrack and stuffing
standing in a dark room with some old
man just from our clarity when did this
happen
this was summer 2017 well cuz it was at
the time it was just another
experimental I was like okay like
there's a plane I'm gonna test the claim
gonna join it okay so II was like I and
I don't join like a Louis through
skeptic I fully unlike right I'm fully
on board with this potentially working
he was innocent until proven guilty so
did you say to anyone I'm gonna go join
the cult or were you're like I'm off to
join the cult no I came back told my
flatmate I was on everything as are and
Barry a contra Dakotas are cool me wait
David is not unfazed amazing so went to
barracks stood in a room with old
some adult men they say begin the old
man start speaking in tongues and so
running around moving and what they were
just normal clothes wears like old men
clothes like cords and a Jackie O show
use checkered shirt official a PFC shoes
off when you go in the room no shoes and
I'm I'm standing there and everyone's
like supposedly being what looks like
being possessed by something I'm
thinking why isn't this working
I want the fun the tangs
the tongues and stuff so there's like
okay yeah eventually and it went on for
half an hour and they will do this I'm
standing it so no counting lie on the
floor did anyone run over you know so
that was a suspicious thing because
they're running around the room and
supposedly totally out of control out of
the bodies but they're this under
coordinated enough to not stand on you
so the spirits that possessed them were
at least polite
we were polite enough yeah and then I
went every Saturday morning at 8 a.m. to
a community center to do this there's me
and one other guy who was the
representative for the Northeast and he
was very patient with me like he was
like it's not working for me like don't
worry to persevere so I did every
Saturday morning for 10 weeks podcast
and eventually I was like look I really
want to give this not a shot because
there's no point just saying Ah try that
it didn't work but I want the Pooh one
and then I want the nocturnal emission
ok that's not as much favorite customer
in the eye have you heard the story
about finding the Isle of Man holding
hands of the German lady yeah okay right
so just before you move on what was what
was supposed to happen with the cult
what's supposed to also do like I don't
know whether it's maybe suggestibility
so like they because they were really
into it like it speaking I don't think
that you're particularly suggestible or
on its a shaker but I want it to be
that's the annoying thing but they know
that you don't want to be suggestive
with us they know it won't easily those
go and think I'll comment get possessed
like what are they trying to do but they
I'm gonna call it possessed but they
like yeah so the spirit moves through
them or something like that
but I did feel I felt like the steady
one which is which is incredibly bizarre
but you felt like the silly one lying on
the floor I love the commitment 10 weeks
to barrack community center to yeah the
local one was just do you remember all
right so remember when I came around to
your house and we had a huge bowl of
spinach in front of you and you were
eating raw spinach from the bowl and I
said why are you eating that massive
bowl of spinach and you said I'm not
sure I'd read something at some point
that said eating a bowl of spinach was
good for me but I can't remember what it
was and I can't remember the effect it's
supposed to elicit you like you find
yourself in a situation you like Arman
passed me a scuppered because I take the
chicken out of the freezer
in this case past me did myself a favor
but didn't explain why so I have a
calendar invite saying eat 200 grams of
spinach like I have read this and it is
and I'm verifying that it
okay like I trust pasta more than anyone
why is so much is that you just go okay
time to do that then when you do it over
so what was the other big poop in the
toilet story we were talking on the
previous podcast last week or some week
some week
Time Warp week about do not live with
seven people lived in a flat with seven
people someone did a big big poo in the
toilet
and it blocked it got halfway caught the
u-bend wouldn't move at all and then
it's a case of just continue to on top
of it
so I boiled the people were all my
flatmate who is one of the smartest
people I've ever met but has a very odd
way of things David well yeah not really
in a I don't describe it because if I
try it's gonna sound like he has
Asperger's it's not in that same mhm
vein but anyway he walked to the nearest
field which is a mile away to get a
steak and walked back dislodged the pea
with the steak and then didn't know what
to do with the PE stick so he took it
back to the field we've done the four
miles of wall just and I took the mick
out of him so I was like why did you
have to go like I understand getting the
stick from the field lining just about
but you don't need to go and put it back
in
the same field like it no one's gonna
miss it as part of that for me I learned
a wife feels like history is complete
it's black in the feeling that circle
yeah but with poop but with poop at the
Pew doesn't matter in the field of
surgeries let me put in the field anyway
what if someone else got to do the same
thing with that same stick take well
tell me face that risk to begin with and
he was okay with that right that's true
yeah what if he already did oh this
that's the P stick yeah but in acoustic
so I don't like the podcast I think wow
I know I think you should can we do I've
got another cracking one don't do it I
don't know if you know I want I want I
want novelty come on
okay